So my goal, my priority since the start of
the coronavirus pandemic has been to be accurately
alarmist for the information that we have,
and there was a period back in, I think it
was December, January, where I was getting
emails from people saying, David, you're overly
alarmist, this isn't going to be anything.
And then there was maybe a little period,
sort of like in May, where I was maybe more
optimistic about the situation than some in
the audience.
But I think that I've done an OK job at more
or less accurately communicating the sort
of status of the situation and the outlook
with the pandemic.
And I have what I think is some accurately
but cautiously optimistic news for you today.
And although the timing of it is interesting,
this is not a political comment, but there
is a mathematical coincidence pointing to
a case and death peak, hopefully the last
one of the pandemic right around the time
of Joe Biden's inauguration.
Now, I'm not making a political segment out
of this.
It's mere coincidence when we I'll show you
the math and the trajectories.
But it seems as though right around January
20th, the day that Joe Biden will be sworn
in as president, that we will be starting
to get past what is hopefully the last peak
of this pandemic.
And again, it's a coincidence.
I'm not claiming January 20th, Joe Biden will
be sworn in and covid will be fixed.
It is merely a timing coincidence.
And we know that these peaks depend on what
happens in the weeks and months leading up.
But I want to go through it with you because
it does feel like we're starting to get into
the tunnel.
At least we're maybe seeing the light or maybe
not.
But we're definitely in the part of the tunnel
that we would consider the latter part of
the tunnel.
Now, as you may know, we've had three coronavirus
peaks in the United States.
Many countries have only had two.
We've had three.
First one was in April.
Second one was in July.
And the third one is right now.
And in this third peak, we've seen cases spike
all the way up to close to two hundred and
fifty thousand cases in a single day, mostly
in the low to 100th to ten, two hundred and
fifteen thousand.
And what you can also see when looking at
the case graph, if you're watching along with
me today is that over the last 10 days, the
rate of case growth has slowed down, meaning
the curve flattened and it even turned downwards
in the last few days.
Now, it is quite possible that there's still
one more peak to go, fueled by holiday and
end of year travel and indoor gatherings.
We shouldn't do them.
It's sort of a foregone conclusion that no
matter what I say, many people are going to
do them.
But the rate of case growth in the US at at
a large, broad level is slowing down.
Looking at the predictions in the models from
a variety of epidemiologists and other experts,
that case peak is expected to be right around
the end of the of the first week of January,
January seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12.
Very rough estimate.
And we know that deaths lag cases by about
three weeks.
And when you look at the death chart right
now, you see a similar pattern to cases.
And while in this third peak, we've started
to see the cases come down a bit, we are only
seeing the growth of deaths slow down.
So we likely are about three weeks behind
in terms of deaths where we are in cases.
So if we see a case peak around it January
10th to pick a date, we would expect to see
a death peak right around February one in
all likelihood.
And this doesn't justify getting careless.
It doesn't do anything to change the tragic
death and destruction that the virus has already
brought to date.
But in all likelihood, that in January will
be the final peak of this pandemic unless
something dramatic changes.
Why?
Because that will not only be the worst moment
in terms of weather and people being indoors.
December, January is the coldest time of the
year in the parts of the U.S. that have winter.
But as the temperature warms and the days
get longer and people spend more time outside,
we will also have the benefit of the vaccination
program.
Vaccination has started in the U.S.
We have the approved vaccine from Pfizer,
emergency use approval.
Second vaccine from Moderna expected to be
approved for emergency use tomorrow.
Third vaccine maybe in the first quarter of
the new year.
So at the same time that we will be peaking
in cases and deaths with the coldest weather
in the most people indoors, we will have,
if all goes to plan, all health care workers
vaccinated by February 1st, all nursing home
residents vaccinated by February 1st.
And we will be in the process of vaccinating
that next most vulnerable group, which will
include the oldest folks and those with the
most serious comorbidities, and by protecting
an additional five to seven percent of the
population each month, starting now.
Going into January, February, March, that
peak we're expecting in January is likely
to be the final one and have a more rapid
decline than without vaccination.
So this is all excellent news, but there is
still a big battle here.
We're still going to have to do all the things
we've been many of us have been doing.
Not all of us masks, social distancing, avoiding
indoor gatherings, but it is mathematically
looking like we're potentially about three
weeks from the case, peak of the pandemic
and five to six weeks from the death peak.
And at that point, the vaccination program
will be more robust with millions of vaccinations
weekly.
So there is a light there.
That's the good news.
Now, given this, we should be extra cautious
in these next months because we're so close.
It's not like, listen, this is going to go
on for two or three more years and we might
be well, for psychological reasons, maybe
we take a screw it attitude and just have
a good time.
Starting now, we will see five ish percent
of the country vaccinated each month.
That's huge.
And we are close to deaths and cases starting
to decline.
So the messages, that's the math of it.
Those are the expectations that were vaccination
is we're just a couple months away from significantly
better circumstances, my friends.
So let's do everything that we can.